- [Pat] Welcome.
We are here today to
talk about Nova 2.0 Lite.
How many folks here have tried out
Nova 2.0 Lite since its launch
less than seven hours ago?
Okay.
- [Jean] You didn't leave the
keynote and do it immediately?
(Pat and Jean laughing)
- [Pat] This might be the first
workshop where we do that.
I'm Pat.
I'm a solutions architect
with the WWSO Bedrock go-to market team,
and I've been working for the
last year with Jean on Nova.
- [Jean] And my name is Jean.
So I'm on the Amazon AGI team.
I am a senior solutions architect.
So happy to be here with you guys today.
- [Pat] Yeah, and I'm
glad the badges work too.
So congrats on getting in.
We're gonna cover a lot today
and we have a rough agenda,
but if we're doing this the right way,
we're gonna be doing a lot of coding.
And unfortunately, some
of it will be mostly
code review given the difficulties here,
but we're gonna go through a lot.
When Jean and I were first planning this,
we had a very tangible bite-size idea
and we quickly realized
this is a huge problem.
So to solve this at scale,
to build a fully autonomous coding agent
has a lot of nuts and bolts.
We're gonna talk about all of that,
but I want to set the
right expectations here
that we may not get through all of it,
but what we want you to see
is how you can prompt Nova 2.0 Lite,
the major considerations to make
if you're gonna do this at scale,
and any of the stuff Jean's going through
or I'm going through, make
sure you ask questions.
We want everyone engaged.
I know it's a large audience,
but that's always the best way to do this.
- [Jean] Yeah. A question.
Show of hands,
how many people have actually
done a code talk before?
Are we familiar with the format?
The goal for this is
we're gonna be in the code
and we're gonna be very interactive.
We wanna be talking.
We wanna hear the questions
that you have as you have them.
This is not 10 minutes at the end Q&A.
This is a conversation
we wanna have with everybody.
So it might be a little bit different
than all the breakout
sessions you've gone today.
It's really, really scrappy.
We're gonna be in the code
and we're gonna be
talking about the model.
- [Pat] Cool.
And I have Leon and
Caesar who I've volun-told
I can call on, which is great.
Does anyone else wanna be called on?
I figured that was the answer.
- [Jean] We'll get you talking
in a second. Don't worry.
- [Pat] So let's talk about Nova,
Nova 2.0 Lite.
So Nova 2.0 Lite was announced today.
It's a large context
window reasoning model.
It comes with built-in
support for our system tools.
You'll get to see some
of that at work here.
It's our next generation of Lite.
We've also announced Pro 2.0 and Omni
that are on the horizon and preview.
But today we're using
Nova 2.0 Lite exclusively
and we're gonna walk you
through how to use reasoning,
how to set budgets, and how
that impacts code generation.
Anything you wanna add there?
- [Jean] No.
- [Pat] So where in Amazon
Nova 2.0 Lite fits in,
like I said, it's got a
1 million context window.
It's actually got 64,000 token output.
So if you are using reasoning,
you will eat through some of that.
But the output of the model,
we've seen perform really well.
Oh sorry, I'm on the wrong screen here.
And it supports all the languages
we've supported thus far.
We're seeing it do really
well at translation tasks.
You can use it to fine tune.
We'll talk about why
you might wanna do that
for code generation use cases.
And yeah, we'll go ahead
and get started in the code.
Jean's gonna get started on
building out this coding agent.
Feel free to follow along in
your notebooks if you want.
- [Jean] Awesome. Yeah, you
wanna switch me over to...
- [Pat] Yeah, okay, okay.
- [Jean] Thanks.
- [Pat] We'll walk through
some of that today, yeah.
- [Jean] Another question.
This can just be a show of hands.
Is everyone familiar with Strands?
Okay, some people are.
I'll give a little bit of
an overview, but I won't...
I'll make sure to cover
what's important here.
What about MCP?
Model context protocol?
Nice.
That's a good amount of the group.
Everybody's...
Has anyone built an agent
using an MCP server before?
Okay, pretty good.
So we're gonna be using MCP today
as well to talk through this.
So to set the scene for where
we're kind of gonna start
and how we're gonna build,
we are gonna have a GitHub issue
that we're working with.
The problem, it's a little
bit meta, but we're...
Yes, question.
Yes, I absolutely can.
Okay, so I am in
a repository, so LangChain AWS.
So LangChain, we have our own dedicated
kind of sub-repository
for the AWS integration.
New model was released.
We wanna make sure we're integrated well
and that we support all the
new features of the model.
This is kind of our meta problem
we're gonna talk through today.
So starting with an actual
kind of GitHub issue
in using a real repository, right?
We're not one-shotting
an entire application.
We're in a real repository with real code
that serves a real business function.
And we're gonna start kind of iterating on
what it looks like to
actually interact with that.
How do we get the model
to understand the context
of the space it's working in?
How do we get it to solve real
business problems in a space
that has been around for a while?
It's a real code app.
So I'm gonna be using Strands,
the kind of high level if
you're not as familiar,
it's kind of like LangChain,
except it's our version and
has really great integration
with AWS services and tools.
So it means that our models
and kind of other things that
we've been building on AWS,
they all really play very nicely together.
And so I'm gonna be using that today to
supercharge really get started
with building this agent.
The nice thing is you see with like a lot
of these agentic kind of
frameworks that you can use,
they do a lot of the code pieces for you.
So I can get an agent going
in a couple lines of code
and what I wanna start with
is just what happens
if I prompt the model, right?
With look at this issue
and comment on the issue with
your implementation plan.
This is extremely vague. I'm
not giving any context at all.
All it has is the GitHub MCP client.
Now we're gonna clear this out
and I'm going to...
Spoiler, I will be going
to a different script
to show you a little bit later,
but we're gonna run this and
we're gonna see what happens.
And I have some boiler
plate code that should be
making this a little bit
nicer and I'm gonna zoom in
'cause I'm sure you can't see it.
It's not as pretty when
I do that. I apologize.
But what's happening here is the model
is starting to call tools.
So the GitHub MCP client,
if I go
and just open up my Python,
I wanna make sure you can see it.
I'm going to
import the client
and we're gonna initialize it
just in a Python execution.
And the goal here
is to show you what the model is seeing
behind the scenes.
So we put a one line prompt
and I initialized a GitHub MCP client.
So GitHub, right?
They provide a couple ways
that you can use their MCP server.
We're just using their remote URL one
and we are-
- [Audience Member 1] Could
you take one 15 seconds
to explain what the MCP is?
I'm still (indistinct)
- [Jean] Yes.
- [Pat] Absolutely. Yeah.
- [Jean] Yeah, so MCP stands
for model context protocol.
It provides a uniform of
standardized way to interact
with arbitrary servers
and things like that
and to allow agents to really
build with them very easily.
So instead of you having to go
and implement every single API
that's gonna interact with GitHub,
you can use their GitHub MCP server
and now I can go get issues,
I can make changes to files,
I can create a branch.
I don't have to implement
any of that myself.
They've kind of created this
standardized interface for me.
And-
- [Pat] And GitHub released their own MCP.
Many companies are.
We're gonna see how you can use it,
how you cannot use it,
but it's gonna be one of the
first tools you're gonna want
to consider when you're
rolling out a coding agent
of any sort.
AWS also has MCP servers for like
all the announcements today
will go into our MCP server.
So if you're building agents that need
to use the latest and greatest,
you can make a tool to go
look that stuff up for you.
- [Jean] Okay.
And you watch...
Okay, so basically if anyone
was really watching me
stumble for a second,
when I am interacting
with a GitHub MCP client,
it took me a couple lines of code
and this is all of the tools
that become available to me.
I can get a comment, add a
comment to a pending review.
I can get team members.
I can get a commit.
I can assign a co-pilot to an issue.
Maybe we don't even wanna
do this code talk today
and we'll just say,
"GitHub Copilot, go do
this for me," right?
And so you have these standardized ways
that you can start
interacting with GitHub,
but what's kind of tricky
here is this is really nice
and this is really easy
for me to get started,
but I did a couple lines of code
and now I'm passing my
model 40 different tools
it has to choose from.
That is a lot of context
the model immediately has
and has to decide what tool to use.
And there's a lot of kind of
things that come into play here
where it's important to be intentional.
It's a very nice thing,
but it's easy to get things
a little out of hand just to begin with.
- [Pat] 'Cause remember
the model gets passed
like a giant tool config, right?
And the model has to
decide of these tools,
which is the most relevant
for what I'm trying to do.
So if you give it five
very well selected tools,
it's gonna have a better chance.
You're not gonna eat
as much context window.
If you give it 20 or 30,
you're really making a big
bet on the model's ability
to traverse long context
and pick the right one.
Nova 2.0 Lite does it
wrong, just gonna say.
But what she's trying to say here
is that's a consideration to make.
- [Jean] Yeah, and I think
you'll see a lot of guidance
for all model families,
and once you get above 20 tools,
they usually recommend breaking
things into sub-agents,
exploring multi-agent architectures.
It's just...
It's a kind of a really
important consideration
that you wanna make.
And what you definitely need,
if you're gonna do that,
is a good system prompt to
give some guidance, right?
I didn't have any system prompt.
I just said, "Go analyze the issue,"
and I am not gonna lie to
you, it did okay, right?
It read the issue, it added a comment.
It made an implementation plan
and I'm gonna even...
I would like to pull up the issue,
make sure my internet,
let's see what it said, right?
I'll implement support for this.
So I'm gonna make a couple steps.
This is all pretty reasonable, right?
With no instructions,
just providing the context of the tools.
It did something that
I think is pretty fair.
What might stand out to you
is, this is all very vague.
It didn't actually read
any of the files, right?
It didn't actually go and
start exploring the repository.
It read the issue, made
a comment, decent plan,
but it's not what I wanted to do, right?
If I'm gonna build a real agent,
I want it to look at the files.
I want it to actually be
interacting with what's real.
So what we can do next,
so if I go back to my Strands agent,
I wanna use this new template
and I'm gonna take a
second here to talk through
just some best practices with Nova 2.0,
and I think a lot of kind
of complex agent prompts
that you'll wanna build overall.
And I'll zoom in.
You need more than just a simple prompt.
And the first line might
look pretty familiar.
We're providing a role.
You do this for like
every agentic application
or any LLM application,
but we need to take it a step further.
So a couple things that you
know we have trained our models
to be good at are these specific
sections that you can use
to draw attention to specific pieces
and workflows and business processes.
So the first one is core mandates.
This is the important business rules
that you need the model to follow.
So one, right?
I don't want you to
update the original issue,
don't edit it, just add a new comment.
Another one is the actual
workflow you want the model
to follow, right?
I want you to get the issue,
but I want you to explore it.
I want you to go and look at the files.
Nova does really well when
we pass the tool names
that we want it to use.
It really draws attention, right?
It links to the tool
configuration it's seeing,
and then I'm having it return
the plan in a specific format,
I have in the output formatting.
Output formatting does really well
when it's at the end of the prompt.
The next section is tool usage.
So you might wonder,
okay, we're passing it,
the tool configuration
is gonna go to the model,
what else would we really have to specify?
And tool usage is where we want
to put the important business rules for us
for how we call the tools.
So MCP is great, it provides
a standardized interface,
but how we...
Sorry, how we want to use the tools
is gonna change based on every single
use case that you're gonna have.
So this is where you kind of bring into
some of the specific things
that are the most important for you.
I always wanna make sure
that we're reading the issue,
providing some kind of
tips around how to interact
with the file paths.
I'm encouraging parallel tool calling.
Parallel tool calling is
when we want the model
to call multiple tools in
parallel instead of waiting
for one after, so kind of
encouraging that behavior.
- [Pat] Actually, I wanna
pause there for parallelism.
Is this a parallel invocation of the model
that's occurring when
you're asking it to do that?
Or is it-
- [Jean] So what'll happen is the model
will in one single assistant response,
it will have two tool calls in it.
And so this might come up
and where I would hope to
see it if it's necessary is
let's see the contents of
multiple files at the same time.
- [Pat] Awesome.
- [Jean] So that's kind of a behavior
that I'd like to encourage,
and then the next thing is
around error handling, right?
It's very nice to assume
that everything will work
perfectly all the time.
But when you're using MCP servers,
when you're using tools
and agented workflows,
things break a lot, right?
Something's gonna time out.
I might do, I don't know,
something else wrong, right?
And so you just wanna start to kind of...
That's the focus of that section
is how do we want it to respond?
If I time out, do I want
the model to try again?
Do I want it to respond gracefully
and give up, fail quickly, right?
So this is kind of where we would start
to think about that section.
So I am going to now
run this again.
I'm just gonna pass it in
the system prompt here.
No other changes necessary, right?
I'm gonna keep the prompt exactly the same
and we're gonna run it
again and we're gonna look
and see how the model changes.
What I'm hoping to see,
we still should read the issue.
I'm hoping the model will start actually
looking at the files, right?
I'm hoping it's going to actually start
kind of exploring the repository,
and fortunately, that is what I'm seeing.
Something you might notice though,
it's gonna be a little bit slower
than it was the first time.
Why is that, right?
It's gonna have to make
a lot of tool calls
because it doesn't have any context about
what this repository looks like at all.
It has no idea.
So what is it gonna do?
It's gonna guess and then
try to like start exploring
and figuring this out.
And a lot of models are very good at that
and it's something that
if I am doing my own
kind of day-to-day job
and I wanna connect to
arbitrary repos, that's fine.
But if I am building a
coding agent for a repository
I know it's mine, we can take
advantage of that, right?
We don't have to make the model explore
by itself all the time.
We can see this is just slow
and I don't blame the model at all.
It's gonna be searching for a repository
and exploring and iterating.
It's fine.
So this is where we get into
this optimization opportunity for context.
So the Nova models, like
Pat mentioned earlier,
support 1 million token context length.
So I wouldn't blame you if the
first thing you thought about
was why don't we just
dump the entire code base
into the model context?
That seems easy, right?
I'll pause here 'cause we got the output,
but you can see eight
tool calls, it did great.
It read the issue.
It explored a lot of different
files, it added the comment.
And I can even...
We can see here the quality
that has improved just
on our system prompt.
We're actually looking
at specific code changes
we want to see happening.
It took a long time to get
there, but it got there,
and now we have real code that
is actually gonna be usable
and relevant to our own repository.
But I wanna improve on this
because I'm not a very patient person
and I think that we could do it better.
- [Pat] Real quick though,
any questions on what Jean
just went through there?
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 2] Yeah.
So when you got (indistinct)
your agent, right?
- [Jean] Yeah.
- [Audience Member 2]
I might have missed it.
Did you specify (indistinct)
because you said (indistinct)
- [Jean] So that's a great question
and it's actually gonna be
one of the optimizations
we're gonna make a
little bit down the line.
At first, I am just
passing all of the tools
and passing all 40 of them,
and you can see like Pat mentioned,
the Nova models, we tuned them for agents,
it does well with 40 tools,
did the right tool calls.
I'm happy with the
decisions it was making,
but that's a lot of tool calls.
And I think the first prompt
where I just have one
line in all of the tools,
it adds immediately over 8,000 tokens
just in the tool config,
which is helpful context,
but it's a lot and it's unnecessary.
And so that's one of the steps we'll take
is kind of short cutting that
and being really intentional.
- [Pat] Yeah, and the quantity of tools
is actually a good place
to start if you're trying
to now make multiple agents
because then you can compartmentalize.
Your tool use is associated
with a behavior you want out of the agent.
So it's a good place to
start if you're moving into
multi-agent architectures.
Did someone else have their hand up?
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 2] The SP
server is running (indistinct)
- [Jean] So I'm using
GitHub's hosted MCP server,
which everybody...
So they have one that you can self-host.
It's just a docker container,
you can run it locally,
but they also have one that's available
just through an API endpoint.
So that's what I'm using today.
Definitely recommend
if you try this at home
and you make your GitHub token,
be smart about the permissions
you put on your GitHub token.
I've done some crazy
things, so learn from me.
- [Pat] We're gonna push to the
LangChain repo today, right?
Just kidding, we're not gonna do that.
(Jean laughing)
- [Jean] So I...
- [Audience Member 3]
Yeah, you look suspicious
when asking (indistinct)
- [Jean] Yes, I did.
You caught me there.
And then one time I
wasn't following my own...
Our own security best practices
and it was starting to push
to the main repo and I was like, no.
And so I made a protected branch
and then I was intelligent.
But it's fun to play with this stuff
and sees what happens.
It's fun to break things.
- [Pat] And tools are an
implicit security boundary too.
Sorry, I know you wanna move on.
- [Jean] Yeah.
- [Pat] If you don't want an agent
to ever do anything
associated with the tool,
you don't give it the tool.
And when you're first iterating on things
like we're doing here,
you'll find those rough
edges really quickly.
- [Jean] Yeah.
So I think there's some...
I guess I went a little
bit on a tangent there
with the tools and everything
that was happening,
going back to how we take
advantage of the context length.
I do wanna show what happens
when we pass the entire code base.
I think it's a very
natural path to take it on,
especially when we have
repositories that can handle
that much context.
And so I have a formatted...
I wrote some a script.
I dumped all of the files.
I'll call out.
I'm using some of our
best practices we have
for how to format for long context.
So I'm gonna be breaking up
the documents in a specific structure.
I will call out,
I did not do something
very nice to the model,
which is instead of passing the path
that is gonna be in the GitHub repository,
I used my local file path.
So not really making it easier,
but at least providing some
context right to the files
and the content in the repository.
So what we're gonna try
to do now is I'm gonna
actually put this in the
prompt, and I believe I...
Yeah, I called it
code base and text.
And I'm gonna say format repo content.
And we're gonna just
put this now at the top,
which is another best
practice for long context.
You'll wanna put that at
the top of your prompt.
And we're going to now run it
and we're gonna see what happens.
And I'm gonna call something out
that you might pick up on really fast.
One, it is a lot slower.
We're passing a absurd
amount of tokens through.
I was smart, I ditched the UV lock
and some other stuff that just threw it
right to the context length.
It's gonna be about 500,000 tokens,
but that's gonna be on
the higher end, right?
Of our token context length.
And there's a lot of
papers around this topic
so we can take advantage
of the context length.
We train for long context,
but something that is kind of seen
across all models is performance
of the model degrades
as the context increases
and a lot aligned with that.
When we do a long context,
a lot of times it's usually
best when we're looking
for something very specific, right?
It's a needle in a haystack.
I want to go search for something
in this long, huge amount of context.
Models are very good at that.
But what's important for
when we're doing code
is semantic connections and
how are things playing together
and that you don't get
as much when you're
just dumping everything
into the context.
And so the benefit doesn't really...
Of having all of it, it's
a little bit tough, right?
What we're probably gonna see
is still very good outputs.
It's probably gonna call less tools,
but it's lot slower and
it's gonna cost a lot more.
- [Pat] And we've seen customers now with
navigating the dependency
of a software project.
Take this in a a whole
direction unto itself,
building a graph of dependencies.
So you can look up
dependencies using a query.
There's a bunch of rag efforts
that can go into making this specific part
of a coding agent more efficient.
But yeah, hopefully you've
got the results so I don't-
- [Jean] Yeah, we'll notice
a couple things, right?
Less tool calls.
So that's kind of nice.
I had to do less steps.
Maybe that saves us a little cost,
but I'll call out what stands out to me
when I see this immediately is
that it didn't add a comment
like I asked it to, right?
The performance of the agent
decreased with all of it,
with all of that context.
And the quality of the
code is still great,
but for agentic workflows,
there is a big trade off here
and you wanna be really intentional
because of this about
managing the context.
And what we see a lot with coding agents
is you can run through
your context so fast
and you don't want to
basically shortcut that
by adding a bunch of
context at the beginning.
You want to allow for the
context to build up naturally
and have more proactive
compaction strategies throughout
the period of the agentic workflow, right?
We don't wanna just kind of
basically handicap, right?
Put the model at a disadvantage
just from the beginning.
- [Pat] How many folks are
using Code Assist in their IDs?
Just any sort of...
Oh, you're willing to admit it.
That's awesome. I do too.
So which you noticed a lot with Kiro,
with like continue, with
any of these plugins,
they're very surgical about
how they look at files.
So they'll go search
for something in a file
and they'll take the line numbers
and they'll put that into the context.
And so just to highlight
what Jean's explaining here,
that's for context management.
They're getting very
specific about the things
they put into the context window.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 4] I'd
like to come ask about that,
so how does it not have
the copies of a full file
and whole code basis?
How is it able to search
and look for a file?
Specific line or does it have
that full context already?
- [Jean] So my proposal to you all to do
and what you'll see if you
really get into the nitty gritty
of how a lot of these like
coding assistants will do, is,
well, they will use the
repository structure
in the context instead.
So one of the benefits, right, of the fact
that we, as humans, have
been working in code bases
for so long is we try hopefully
to design them in a way it's intuitive
and easy for us to navigate.
So now we have the ability to
just take advantage of that.
It's designed for us to
be able to navigate it.
I hope if you're lucky,
you've been at companies
where maybe we're not as good about that,
but you have human
preference tuned file pass
that provide context out of the box for
what is probably gonna
be happening in the file.
And you can provide that to the model
and it gives it a starting
point of where to look.
And so what I have now is a separate
text file that has all of the file paths
in the entire repository.
I'm not at this moment providing
any additional context to it,
but I'm providing the file pass.
And you can see here,
I think the thing I called
out in the issue itself
is add something to the
Chat Bedrock Converse class.
We can see here we have this file path
that says Bedrock Converse.
It probably is gonna give a
hint to the model that, oh,
that might be a really good
place for me to start looking.
And so if we switch this out now
and we just instead
pass this new text file
that has the file list
and try to run that, we
should see a couple things.
Ideally, the wifi holds up, right?
It's just going a bit faster.
We should still see a pretty high quality
output from the model.
And so this kind of really
easy tuning, to be honest,
it wasn't a very hard script to write.
And so this helps us
kind of very easily provide
context to the model.
And while that's running,
I will show the fact...
Te next step that you can take it
is actually sorting the
file paths and stuff.
And if you are willing to put the time in,
this is another way
that you can be a little
bit more intentional
about providing the context of the model.
And a lot of...
I think what I've noticed,
a lot of repositories that
want to be really easy
for agents to work in,
they'll provide this kind of
stuff in the agent MD file
and things like that.
And so it's being a little slow.
I will say I'm gonna blame the wifi,
but so far we've only
had two different tools
that are gonna be called.
We're getting another file contents,
and so we'll see what
the output looks like.
And what I'm hoping for, right,
is we'll get a high quality output
with the implementation plan.
- [Pat] And so one thing
that to keep in mind,
because agents, in particular,
are token hogs, right?
We know they use a lot of tokens.
Code bases will eat
through those tokens faster
than you can blink in eye.
So the other reason to be conscious about
how many tokens you're using
in your time to this window,
how good your tools are is
because that's a measure
of cost in the long run.
So if you're running this agent
for every single issue that gets submitted
and it's running autonomously,
there's a consideration for cost.
We'll see the output tokens
here, but it's considerable.
We're only doing a
pretty straightforward...
- [Jean] Yeah.
Yeah, and so we can see the output now.
We had a significant reduction
in the tool calls from
the first one where we provide no context
to the repository.
We also, in comparison to the one
where we're passing the
entire code base, right?
This is a lot more reasonable
on the input tokens
that are going into the model.
And then the quality still of the output
that we're getting is still very high.
We're still going to be making
very specific code changes
that were targeted for the files
that will have the impact that
we want for the GitHub issue.
So this is all good things
if we're thinking about
a autonomous coding agent
in terms of planning, right?
We're gonna do a long horizon coding task.
We want high quality planning
at the beginning, right?
If you're using a coding tool,
you wanna plan and then you act.
It's the same when you're
building it yourself.
We put a lot of time into
building a high quality plan.
This is only so helpful
because at this point, nothing's
actually writing any code.
I still have to go
implement the plan, right?
We want to build on this
and we want to actually build something
that can take actions in the code base.
So the option for us,
we have two basically.
We can either continue to
build on the current agent
that we have or we can start to expand
upon a multi-agent
implementation strategy.
Now there are a lot of cons
with a mono agent architecture here.
And we're being really repetitive,
but a lot of it comes to the context.
We're gonna put all of these tool calls
and context just to create the plan.
All that really matters from the plan
is the output of the plan.
And then if we build on top of that,
we're still tracking all of
the tokens that we use to get
to the plan to then act
and actually build it.
So what you'll see in a
lot of the coding agents
and kind of the direction we want
to go now is a multi-agent architecture.
And we will start with
using Strands still and
we're gonna implement it
using a graph-based approach
where we will have a planning agent
and then an act agent.
Our plan agent, right?
It will do all the tool
calls to look at the files
and determine what needs to happen.
And then that output
will go to our act agent.
The act agent will take
the implementation plan
and it'll actually start
iterating and writing the code.
So where the direction we've
been going so far, we might...
You might assume we're
going to use the GitHub MCP.
So one thing you might pick up on
and I'll call out is when we
use the GitHub MTP server,
every single file, every single tool call
where I'm getting the file contents,
I am getting the entire file
contents from their API.
It's a lot. It's quite slow.
And then if we do the
create update changes,
we're also outputting the entire file
through a tool call back to the server.
So it's very, very slow
and not necessarily the most practical
way to do it.
But we'll get to that a little bit later.
A little bit of a teaser.
So we'll try it out.
So I have two agents, like I said.
I'll just show very quickly in Strands,
if you've done a graph approach before,
what you'll do is you'll
create this graph builder,
you'll add your nodes
and that's really it.
It's quite easy.
- [Pat] Is everyone familiar with
the basic agent orchestration patterns?
I'll go over those really
quick if that helps.
So the most ubiquitous
pattern right now in agents
is the manager agent and the subagents.
The manager agent dictates
when and who it calls to get work done
and it decides when the work is done.
Absolutely a thing.
There's also graph agents.
You can think of it as a left
to right graph in our case,
for coding where every
agent is a dependent
on the previous node.
They call them nodes.
That's also...
There's different names for it.
Kiro AI has its own terminology.
Strands has its own terminology.
But the idea is that the
agents are moving left to right
and once they move to the right,
they don't come back.
So in code projects,
you typically have that.
If you've used Kiro,
it feels like a left to
right process, right?
They have a requirement doc
or design doc requirements
and then implementation
and then unleash the agents
and do the things.
So those are the two most
ubiquitous orchestration patterns.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 5] So are
all the agents in a group chat
and based on the annotation,
the manager will know how to assign?
- [Pat] I'm sorry, I missed that.
- [Audience Member 5] So is
Strands doing like a group chat
of the agents behind the scene
or are they talking to each other?
- [Pat] A group chat? That'd be cool.
No, essentially what's happening
in a graph agent orchestration
is when the agent's done,
you can send the result of
that agent to the next one
and then it picks up where it left off.
You can send state to it.
You can propagate the input
from the original all the way
to the last agent.
But no, they're not commingling
and talking about things.
That would be more of the
manager agent orchestration.
You can ask it to do a
whiteboarding session,
update a markdown file with your ideas,
let's take votes based on what you think
of what's been proposed, stuff like that.
- [Audience Member 5]
And the manager assigns
based on the annotation?
- [Pat] Yeah, the manager agent says,
and this would go in your prompt, right?
You'd say you are a manager agent,
you're assessing the work.
You have a implementation agent.
It's responsible for this.
You have a coding agent.
And you're relying on the
reasoning ability of the model
to decide which agent to work with.
So you're leaving that completely
up to the manager agent.
- [Jean] So I have it running.
I'm actually not even gonna let it
kind of continue all the way
just 'cause we only have 20 minutes left
and we're gonna get to
some really cool stuff.
But the message I wanna
give here is we're able
to switch into this
multi-agent architecture.
We still have a disadvantage
because it's still really slow.
And so the path that we
wanna talk through now
that Pat's gonna take over a bit,
is how can we build this
more locally centric?
How do we create an environment
that we can actually make the code change
and test the code changes?
Because that's gonna
be a lot more practical
for these kinds of applications.
- [Pat] Let's do it.
- [Jean] Let's do it.
- [Pat] I'll have to
show you what I wrote,
which I know isn't as
exciting, but we've had some...
My laptop doesn't connect well,
so I've neglected this side of the room.
I hope you're all getting
as much out of this
as I hope you are.
So let's talk about a
couple quick concepts.
So when you write code,
you never just write it
and then send a...
And then push it.
I mean, some of you might be
that good at writing code,
but you've got to make
sure it actually executes
and it actually does
what it's supposed to do.
And we take that for granted.
As developers, we run the
code, we write a test,
and if it works, it works.
If it doesn't, you write more unit tests
and you keep iterating until it's done.
So how do you get an agent
to do that on its own
'cause it doesn't have a workspace?
Well, you give it a workspace.
What I wanna talk about now
is how to maybe do that
with code execution.
How can you use Docker to create
a workspace for this agent
to put some files in it,
mount it to the image or
the container, run it,
see what happens,
get the exception and keep iterating.
And this is something that
we're seeing a lot of folks do.
They might have a container
image that they've baked
for their pipeline that they want to use.
Those are great candidates, by the way.
We're gonna show you a really
simple example on Docker.
Before I go there,
let's take a look at that tool.
So I called it the code execution tool.
By the way, in Strands,
as long as you're doing things
and following the rules,
anything you put in the tools
directory can be sucked up
by the agent without question, right?
That's good and bad,
'cause if you've got hundreds of tools,
that gets to be a problem.
But if you're building
agents for the first time,
it's a good way to get started.
Code execution.
I'll walk through a few things here.
Oh, you have your scroll reverse.
Okay, not reverse, it's the right way.
It's the right way to scroll.
So what I've done here,
and I've just hard coded
a default workspace path.
But what's gonna happen
here is I'm gonna tell it,
put all your work in
this docker workspace.
If you're gonna clone anything,
if you're gonna write any code,
make sure it goes in there
and put your tests somewhere else.
And you make sure
that we're keeping these things separate.
File system security
and network security
are also a thing, right?
You don't wanna...
If you go deploy this and
you let it ping the internet,
go pull down any library it wants,
completely unvetted by your security team.
These are all super important
considerations to make.
Anthropic in late October
released Sandbox Runtime.
I would highly suggest
taking a look at it.
They have, I think in
a very thoughtful way,
offered a great tool for solving that.
You can send all your traffic
to a proxy if you want.
If you don't want this
agent doing anything else,
you can lock down the files
or the directories it has access to.
We're not gonna get into that today,
but I wanted to put that out there.
There's also agent core code interpreter
that is designed specifically
for this use case.
So my execute docker
tool, just like all tools,
you want to give it good descriptions.
Again, remember the context.
All of that goes into the context.
Like when Strands picks up the tool,
it's picking up the description
to help it decide what it's doing.
I got a little carried away here,
but it's important to remember that.
I'm sending it back a return error
if I don't have the right information.
Dependencies.
So how are you gonna tell the agent to...
If it needs to do a PIP install
or it needs to like get
the environment ready
before it executes the code,
you need to tell it where to put it.
So requirements text is gonna
be a really important thing.
I'm using Python,
so of course, if you're using
node or some other language,
that's gonna be N number of
steps to complete, as we know.
But here we just got a
simple docker command.
So if I have all the requirements,
I'm gonna include the requirements dock.
If I don't, then I don't.
But I've pulled down a container image,
I'm telling it the workspace to use
and I'm gonna pip install everything
before I do a single thing,
before any code runs.
So I have parody with my test environment,
my prod environment.
So you can imagine,
you probably wouldn't do this for reels.
You'd probably have a container
that's hardened and everything.
But we're moving fast here.
Any questions on this approach?
Any worries about doing this, this way?
Leon's like, "Yeah, what do you think?"
- [Audience Member 6] I'm
interested in the results.
- [Pat] You wanna watch it just explode?
Yeah, so files-
Yeah, go ahead. Oh yeah.
- [Audience Member 7] So do you prevent
from downloading any packages,
which might have (indistinct)
or you're not considering
this at this point?
- [Pat] Yep.
The question was how do
you prevent the agent
from downloading packages
that are either not approved
or are not from your artifact repository,
which is what most enterprises are doing.
That's where you'd want
to give a lot of thought
to locking down which
addresses it's allowed to use.
And that's why using a proxy is good.
Sandbox Runtime lets you say only allow
anything to this domain.
If it's going anywhere, it has
to go through this address.
That's one way.
You could create a separate tool
or a separate agent to
prepare the dependencies.
Do it in a secured manner,
get the trust of your security department
and maybe they manage it,
and that's a way to do it.
There's a lot of angles you could take,
but yeah, it's worth thinking about.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 8] (indistinct)
- [Pat] Yeah, it's just in Docker,
it's probably not gonna go anywhere.
No, it's probably not.
But Docker is leveraging
my network hardware, right?
So we get to hand wave that, yeah.
But if you're launching
or spawning a container
in an ECS cluster, that's gonna
be managed for good reason,
but you wouldn't want it reaching out
through your NAT gateway
and just like PIP installing
whatever it feels like pip installing,
'cause I can tell you, it'll end poorly.
Did you have a question?
Okay.
Cool.
And so this executes
runs the Docker command
and then returns.
And again, I'm sorry we
had this while working,
but we can't get this laptop working.
It returns errors if it doesn't work.
Okay, so code execution,
I'll show you the Docker
file I've written for this
if that helps clarify.
It's roughly what you would expect.
You're setting the work
directory to Docker workspace.
If your code has to create things
and has to persist things,
that's a consideration too.
If its task is to
actually output more code
or output artifacts you
need for some other process,
telling it where to put
it is also important.
Go put it in S3.
You could put it locally,
but then when the container
dies, you lose it.
So these are the same
considerations you'd make
in any surveillance architecture.
But yeah, in our case,
a very simple docker file.
Okay, I'm gonna show
you how we've proposed,
in this case at least.
You build a multi-agent that does this.
Is this multi-agent one mine?
The red one? The one with errors?
- [Jean] No, no, I cleared them.
I staged the commit.
- [Pat] Got it, got it. Okay.
And I don't know if you've seen this yet,
and actually, why don't
we go through this?
Oops.
- [Audience Member 9] Question.
- [Pat] Yeah.
- [Audience Member 9]
Is all this gonna run
on our local machine?
Or is this running (indistinct).
Sometimes running VS Code.
This is the coding agent using,
is this gonna create a
container locally on a laptop
or this (indistinct)
- [Pat] Yes, for this very
trivial coding agent example,
we're just using the Docker
Runtime on your desktop.
Yeah, but-
- [Jean] Where might you
wanna host it, on AWS?
- [Pat] Yeah, you might wanna
host it on ECS or Fargate
or whatever favorite container
platform you're using.
Remember that when the agents...
When this is running in a CICD pipeline
or it's running in GitHub actions,
you've got to orchestrate
where that compute and
that runtime occurs.
Yeah. Does that answer your question?
Okay.
- [Jean] Yeah, 'cause
I think when I imagine
kind of some practical applications
of this kind of use case, right?
We have coding agents that run
locally all the time, right?
So it's why would I wanna do this?
I see the benefit here,
actually running in your...
Like a GitHub Action or things like that,
you want it to be able to
kind of spawn in a place
that's not local all the time.
Obviously we have one hour.
That would be crazy cool if we could talk
through all of this in one hour but...
- [Pat] Yeah, we're gonna try.
(Pat and Jean laughing)
But we have 10 minutes left
so I'm gonna keep going
and please raise your hand for questions.
I want to show you how to actually...
I don't think we've gone through
how to actually make
a request to Nova yet.
So we have a model helper here
where we're wrapping the
Strands Bedrock model class
and putting Nova 2.0 Lite in there
for a lot of heavy reasoning tasks.
If you're traversing a big context,
you're gonna want to actually
use reasoning on high.
- [Jean] Right, 'cause I mentioned this
in the keynote session today.
The Nova 2.0 Lite model we're
specifically talking about
in Pro and Omni that are
announced in preview,
there are extended reasoning models.
So you can turn reasoning on or off.
It defaults to off and then you might...
If you're familiar with using
other extended reasoning models,
you might be used to setting budget tokens
or something like that.
We do it a little bit differently.
So we have reasoning budgets
and so we group them
into three categories,
low, medium, and high.
And so they'll use different amount
of tokens in their reasoning.
And so this is kind of T-shirt
sizing that you can use
to control the amount of
reasoning that's done.
And don't always think that
more reasoning is better,
for obvious reasons.
Output tokens.
Reasoning high can use up
to 32,000 output tokens.
So we can imagine really complex problems.
It's a really cool thing,
but it's cost and time.
- [Pat] Yeah, and we've actually found
if you use too much reasoning,
that is a possibility and
the outputs can degrade.
So something to keep in mind.
- [Jean] Yeah, question.
- [Audience Member 10] We
have just one model deployment
for all the previous agents.
So now you have to show four models?
- [Jean] Yeah, these are
just different configurations
of the same model for helper.
Just to make things a little bit easier.
The question was just if we had four.
Previously, I was just
re-using reasoning medium
and so I was using the same model.
- [Audience Member 10] And
all the agents use that?
- [Jean] Right.
- [Pat] Yeah.
- [Jean] And now you can also...
I think it's a really good question too
when we think about multi-agent,
'cause you can tune it
for the actual task.
Maybe you wanna have
more complex reasoning
for the initial planning
phase that you want
to do less reasoning for
the act or the validation.
You don't need that much reasoning
if you wanna add that at the end, right?
- [Pat] Sorry, I'm trying to
make sure I get all the hands.
Okay, let's talk about...
Where was I with the actual agent here?
Yeah, so we understand roughly
how the tool would be orchestrated
so you can get code execution.
In this example, I've taken
the liberty to make a...
Create enhanced plan agent.
So some of the bottlenecks
that Jean's example ran into
was how does the model even know
what the repost structure is like?
Well, now we're getting into
basic file system tools, right?
So any of these IDE tools
that you're working with,
they have show me a directory tree.
Show me the first three files,
show me the first 100 rows of the file.
Look for anything in the
file that has this in it.
Then expand and give me
like the previous in following 20 lines.
So you very quickly
find yourself building.
You have to build those
tools for the agent to use.
Because like we said, you can't just dump
the 15,000 line Python
files into the context
and expect it to perform well.
It's gonna be expensive and
it's just not gonna be accurate.
So you very quickly find
yourself building tools
that the agent can use.
And so what we show here is
we have some file system tools
called show directory tree,
GIT directory summary.
Like how many files are in this thing?
We are using some GIT tools.
So as you move off of GitHub MCP
to your local workspace,
like any developer actually does,
you're gonna want GIT
tools and that's scary
'cause you can do
dangerous things with GIT,
but in this case, all
we're doing is clone.
So we're just cloning the repo.
We're cloning the repo down
and then we're telling it,
"Hey, use these tools to explore,
do a code analysis.
Read the issue and tell me
where I should be making changes and how."
We're all-
- [Jean] One question
I'll throw in there too.
I think it's worthwhile to explore
and I'm just gonna call
it out there, right?
We're no longer passing
the entire GitHub MCP
tool config, all 40 files.
We're narrowing it down, right?
You can see he's saying issue
read, add issue comment,
there are still value
to using the MCP server.
Those tools provide a lot of utility,
but the ones that are
gonna require a lot of data
and everything that's passing through
and can have this benefit
we can take advantage
of the local code environment, right?
It's better to use the tools, right?
That Pat is talking about.
- [Pat] How many have
built file system tools
or anything for their
agents and gone that far?
How has it gone?
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 11]
We never thought about
doing everything in (indistinct).
So the first step was always (indistinct)
I didn't even think about
(indistinct) specific parts
because I saw the model
wouldn't give any context.
- [Pat] Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and even...
So the other step you could
take is we were talking before,
like a lot of repos
have a contributing MD.
Tell the agent to take a look at that.
Until super intelligence is here,
all of these agents will
be coupled very tightly
to the repository they're associated with.
That's just inevitable.
You're gonna have to prompt it
on guidelines for contributing.
You'll probably have more information
on where to find things in the prompt.
You're gonna have to
couple this agent tightly
to your repo unless you've completely...
Your development practices are
completely ubiquitous across
all code bases, which is rarely the case.
Okay. I'm gonna quickly get through here.
Lastly, I guess I'll show you
the agent prompt if that would help.
But we're creating a Strands agent.
We're using reasoning low.
You could use high. High
is gonna take a while.
It's also gonna be
generally more expensive
'cause you're using more
tokens to arrive at the answer.
So let's take a look at the prompt
and then we're at just
under four minutes left.
So I'll try and go through this quickly.
And I'll do word wrap here
so we can actually see.
Yeah, so you are an
enhanced planning agent
with GitHub issue validation capabilities.
I'm sort of telling it what an issue is,
determine whether it's
a bug or a user error,
'cause right, a lot of issues are like,
"Yo, go check the read me."
This is the wrong way to use it.
So validating whether
this is a legitimate issue
or if it's a feature.
You can imagine too, these
are tracks you might go down
where you're gonna handle
features completely differently.
Right?
Or you're gonna handle
bug fixes with some level
of urgency in assessing
the urgency of the issue.
But again-
- [Jean] And I don't...
Yeah, I wanna call this out too.
We might notice models
really love the users, right?
And if we have an agent
that's just gonna go
and change the repository
every single time the user
makes a mistake and it's just
not using things correctly,
that'd be way out of hand, right?
We don't want it to do that.
And so it is an important consideration
because a lot of times people...
I don't know if you guys are
managing any open source repos,
but they might be commenting
things all the time
that are just like, that's
not how you do this.
- [Pat] Yeah.
And we have some repositories
from SaaS at Amazon
who are already managing their
repository in this manner.
So I can send you an example.
- [Jean] Wait, we had a question too.
- [Pat] Oh yeah.
- [Audience Member 12] Basically
what you're doing is coding
another team member of your team,
which will be responsible for
resolving some specific task
that you're assigning to it.
- [Jean] Right.
- [Audience Member 12]
Perfect for the night.
(Pat and Jean laughing)
- [Pat] Yeah, there's
some dynamism here though
that changes over time, right?
If the things that you
bake into your prompt,
you're gonna have to keep revisiting this.
We haven't even talked
about agent evaluation,
which is analogous
to employee performance evaluation, right?
So not sidestepping all that,
but yeah, a lot of it is
very analogous to that.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member 13] Can you do this
when a PR is submitted?
(indistinct)
- [Jean] So the question
is if you can do this
when a PR is submitted.
I think I would see a
different application maybe
when a PR is submitted doing a code review
or things of that nature.
I think what we're looking at here
is almost reactive to specific issues
that are opened on our repository.
Something is reported as a failure.
How can we go and create the PR
that would have the fix
and then have the human go
and kind of do the review and emerge it.
- [Pat] Yep. Yep.
- [Jean] Okay. We are out of time.
- [Pat] Yeah, we're more or
less out of time I think.
Probably a good place to stop.
Any questions? Yeah, go ahead.
- [Audience Member 14] (indistinct)
- [Pat] Sorry, say that again?
- [Audience Member 14] Is the
(indistinct) for this code?
- [Pat] Yeah, we'll publish
the repo for this code.
Yeah, yeah. We'll make it available.
- [Audience Member 15] (indistinct)
- [Jean] Yes. Yeah, we can do all of that.
We'll do that.
- [Pat] We're just gonna push it
to the LangChain repo and just...
- [Jean] No, just kidding.
- [Pat] Kidding.
Yeah. Well, thank you
for joining, everybody.
It's been an absolute pleasure.
I'm sorry we had the
technology issues, but...
- [Jean] If you have...
The point of this wasn't to
go too much into the features
of the Nova models, right?
It's not a breakout session,
it's talking about the code.
If you have questions about
any of the new releases,
the quick PSA, we have
a booth at the expo.
People there all the time
that can answer questions.
But yeah, I hope that you got some value
out of this and had a good time.
I appreciate it.
(audience applauding)